certainly when I think about performance
in the classroom we focus on performance
as process and not performance as
product I think a lot of times people
think about performance only as the last
step and it's the final presentation and
they get one shot and they can't mess it
up and that just raises the stakes so
unnecessarily around something that is
already kind of scary but instead if we
think about what is the process of
performance process of performance
involves risk taking involves
vulnerability involves experimenting
involves joy involves wanting to be here
involves the audience involves who are
you talking to what are you saying how
can you best communicate all those
things what are the strategies and
performance you can use so that your
audience receives exactly what you want
them to these are all of the parts of
performance that we deal with and
experiment with throughout as we're
writing as we're creating so that the
emphasis is less on one final
performance and more on how is
performance
used and how can we make use of it as
communicators the easiest way to
minimize stage fright I have found is to
lower the stakes around performance so
by allowing people to just be more
familiar and have more experiences with
performance instead of just one final
performance they're already used to this
is what it feels like when I'm in front
of an audience this is what my body
feels like this is what happens when I
sweat a lot before I go onstage this is
what a microphone feels like all of
those things if they're more familiar
with them then getting up on stage feels
less foreign and feels less terrifying
so that's the easiest way to combat
stage fright is just a lot of practice
and a lot of familiarity with the
elements of performance and what's going
to happen when you're on stage a lot of
times when people have stage fright
there's a little voice in the back of
their head that's going oh oh I'm gonna
be up there all alone and everyone's
gonna be watching me and everyone's
gonna be waiting for me to mess up so
they can be like ah hi knew it you suck
and that's very unrealistic for two main
reasons one is that when you're on stage
you're not alone you're in a room full
of people and it's important to remember
that for many reasons but a big one is
that those people all are a part of this
moment with you and they want to enjoy
themselves the second reason why that
fear doesn't make any sense is because
no one ever goes to see a lot of
performance and sits down and is like me
I hope it is gonna be terrible right no
nobody does that you go to see a live
performance and you go oh I hope that
this is great I hope I enjoy myself I
hope this is so great that later people
are like oh you got to see that that's
amazing that's what your audience feels
when they're watching you and if you can
remember that you can say oh everyone
here is wanting to have a good time
they're looking at me for permission to
have a great time and one of the best
ways for them to have a great time is
for you to have a great time when I talk
about performance I usually talk most
about experimenting and enjoying
yourself I really believe that those are
the two most critical things that you
can focus on when you're performing
trying things out seeing what works what
you like what you want to keep for next
time when you might want to change and
also genuinely enjoying yourself if you
don't want to be there nobody else does
either if you get on stage and you're
like I really wish I wasn't here right
now everyone in the room goes oh I
really wish I wasn't here right now but
if you get on stage you're like hey I'm
really excited to be here what's gonna
happen everybody the room goes oh I'm
happen that's the effect you have on
everybody based on what energy you are
pouring into their room it doesn't mean
that you can't be nervous I think
sometimes people think that either
you're nervous or you can do a good show
and it can't be both but that's not the
case most of the time when I'm onstage
I'm incredibly nervous but I'm also
enjoying myself because I have to be if
I'm not enjoying myself nobody else is
either